all right
here we are
august
super poscovid
q a
and so um
yeah
august was crazy my goodness august was
insane at least for me i went to europe
participate
participated in uh in a manifesto uh
event which was pretty intense i have to
say
just um
very intense uh weekend
and then i spent a day in um
i spent a day i spent a few more days
there in denmark
and it was great it was wonderful and um
and then i got coveted yeah so i got
kovit i got back here
and
i was tested at the airport
if
here
just avoid kind of the social stigma and
the social problems we i really
self-isolated from my family then the
result was positive two days later i got
the positive results and so i moved out
of the house and lived basically outside
the house and attend for a few days and
then my wonderful wife found a uh like a
camper trailer that someone on my street
had and so we rented it for um for the
week
so uh yeah so i really did get copied it
was like it was like this just this
really bad flu that lasted uh lasted a
whole week
um
and i lost my sense of smell and of
taste
so i was very
just my brain was in complete fog which
is why i didn't make any videos you know
during that time i actually carved a lot
which was great it was actually
wonderful i could just carve all day and
it and that was fine because it didn't
take up my brain
um
and so yes i am recovered i'm back my
sense of smell and taste have come back
in the past
three four days but i'm still i'm still
super exhausted it's like it really you
know i i feel like i have energy and
then at some point during the day i just
totally burn out and uh
so that's been pretty intense um and uh
so so that has been this month and today
i was interviewed by the babylon bee
which was a lot of fun and so look
forward to that i'm at when they're
gonna
going to put it out um it was it was a
little intense i guess because i think i
don't know how much they knew about what
i was doing
um
i know how much they knew about what i
was doing
uh so so i think they were surprised at
some of my answers but it ended up being
fun
there was some funny moments in it so
you should definitely watch it
and what else is there going on yes
uh something some of you might will be
very happy to hear
is that
next thursday so the second september
2nd at 7 00 p.m eastern
i will be on jay dyer's channel we'll be
talking about iconography
and so another a lot of people have been
looking forward to that
for a very long time so i'm pretty happy
that it's
it's finally happening you know we had
some we had some kind of
misunderstanding and some issues and i
feel like we really worked through them
and that you know the let's say that
the respect between us is mutual and so
i think it's a it's a good time so uh so
we're gonna do that we're gonna do that
um
the next few days so look forward to
that
on what else is going on there's a lot
of stuff going on and then
on
on friday is it on friday i think
no it's next week next week on the 10th
i'm inter i'm having
another discussion with uh jordan
peterson with john viveki and so if you
guys watch that conversation between
jordan and john
that was crazy that was a crazy
conversation it was extremely manic and
intense and so um
i'm both looking forward to that and
let's be honest
a little nervous about about that
conversation
so there's a lot of stuff look something
else that you might want to pay
attention to i'll be posting about it on
social media i'm on my website as well
on the 25th of september i'll be
speaking at the uh
jung society of montreal and so they
invited me to to come speak it's going
to be on zoom so if people want to get
tickets i don't know how much it is but
you can get tickets and you can
participate in that event um
yeah just a bunch of stuff just a bunch
of stuff going on so uh i don't know if
there's anything else
i'm supposed to be in florida in october
to speak at the at uh the oca
uh diocese of the south
as a keynote speaker but um and i'm
supposed to be in chicago as well to
participate in a catholic art conference
in october
as well but with all the weird travel
stuff and now our covet passport is
starting tomorrow yay hooray for covet
passports
tomorrow
uh starting tomorrow those that are not
vaccinated cannot access any
public spaces you can't go to a
restaurant can go to a theater it can go
to participate to a gym participate in
any sports activities and uh and so
that's starting tomorrow so uh yes
that's just just
just great just that's uh
that's just great we just uh
super happy about you know this whole
system of the beast thing kind of just
manifesting itself
slowly but surely
all right sorry
okay let's stay positive
tonight because there are so many so
many questions so many questions i don't
know how to deal with this anymore
there's like
someone in the chat said we gave you a
hundred questions because
we have no manners that's what it feels
like well it's not anybody's fault
everybody just puts in one question so
so yes i um
i think there's something like uh
like 80 questions and so
i don't know i don't we'll make it
through we'll see we'll make it through
we'll try we'll do what we can
so uh so yes so let's see in the chat um
are there some of my folks in the in the
chat
is uh are lisa brad there jacob
maybe um
other people
we'll see
hopefully there are because we know it
gets crazy in the chat sometimes
okay so here we go let us start we will
start with uh
the website so i hope nobody's still
having yes vincent harris says coughing
equals coronavirus um you know what i
don't think it's the coronavirus it
might have made it worse but one of the
things that that happened during my
covid is that i spent the whole week in
my workshop
you know all day
for uh for like 10 days and uh i started
coughing like crazy and i thought it was
copied but i think
i think i have silica in my lungs i
think that um
because it's been kind of happening
before i noticed that i run out of
breath you might have seen me sometimes
in interviews sometimes i kind of run
out of breath and uh it's possible that
i have uh silica in my lungs which is
really bad
um and um
yeah it's very bad so i need to find
solutions to that or else i won't be
able
or else i actually will have to stop
carving because it can it can it can
ruin your lungs completely
okay so anyways
so a lot of joy somebody asked the green
knight movie i haven't watched it yet so
uh i can't interpret that so i don't
know i don't know i will watch it i'm
for sure i'm gonna watch it everybody
tell me i need to watch it so i
definitely will watch it but um i
haven't watched it yet
i'm going to make a video i want to make
a video on the loki series just the last
episode because there was so many weird
interesting things about the garden of
eden and the temptation and
that this kind of presentation of
extremes and how you know it was
presented like they had no solution
so anyway so i'm gonna do probably a
video on on that i still have my video
about the mark of the beast which as you
can see i'm very much hesitating to make
because
because a lot of stuff has happened
and part of it has been that i've been
somewhat warned by people i respect and
people who knew elder saint pauicios
um about some of the things that saint
paul's seo said he did say them but just
i've been warned to be careful about
that and so
i want to make sure that i'm not uh just
pouring oil on a fire but i i also think
it's important to to kind of talk about
this stuff so uh so yeah so let's go all
right here we go so the more i talk the
less i'm answering questions and since
there are a lot of questions i need to
do that
okay so nicos asks
maybe that better formulated are we
determined to be free or are we free to
be slaves
and so
the
the idea is that there really is only
one freedom
and that the freedom
the only freedom we have is is to
move let's say in humility towards god
and so as we submit to god we actually
become free it might seem like some kind
of paradox but it actually isn't a
paradox it's actually very coherent
because
the slavery we have is is uh is usually
it's at least especially personally it's
at least it's lateral and it's lower
it's like we're slaves of our desires
we're slave of a of a tyranny of your
passions something things that are
controlling you um
and the the slavery happens here right
the slaver happens happens in your mind
um
and in your in the way that you
interpret your situation
but as you kind of move towards god then
you become free in the sense that you
might actually
be
led to your death you might actually be
tortured you might actually be
persecuted all these things might happen
to you but those things won't determine
you and that's that's
what let's say the difference between
slavery and true freedom is is that even
though things will happen to you
and outwardly you might look like you're
constrained
uh but inwardly you are free because
you get your identity you get your um
yeah you get your identity from from
above and so
you don't you don't feel weight you're
not weighed down by the things that are
constraining you outside you so that's
actually the freedom and say maximus
presents it that way the only freedom is
choosing god when you choose other
things aside from god that's when you
become a slave so it's not about being
able to do whatever you want that's not
the idea but you but anyways but it's
all it's discovering that what you
really want
deep down inside is to be united
with your origin to united with that
which is you know the source of you so
yeah
okay so all right sorry nicos i'm taking
only one question per person or else
this is not it's not going to work so
i'm going to skip your question
your second question timothy aspeslaw
asked hey jonathan glad to hear you're
feeling better what are your latest
recommendations for example a new book
you've been reading or a podcast you
just found
hope you feel better every day
thank you
um
i'm reading right now i'm i'm looking at
an interesting book i'll show it to you
i don't know where it is
where did i put it
sorry i can't i don't know where i where
i put it it's something it's something
like uh it's like the plan to kill god
or the conspiracy to kill god and it
looks at uh the the real
strategies that the communists used in
uh in uh russia to destroy religion and
how it was active hostile atheism
and i'm just reading that just because i
just want more more arsenal towards
people who kind of portray
um
secularism and atheism as this benign
force as this kind of live and let live
force but definitely in the communist
era it was an active antitheism you know
and the strategies that you can find are
interesting because you can kind of see
uh
kind of see on the horizon some of these
strategies
appearing i'm also reading uh father
stephen uh father andrew dominic's new
book uh is it oh god arise and so i'm
really excited about that i haven't
started it yet but that's really like
the next thing i'm gonna look into and
i'll also have father andrew on my
channel
very soon to talk about his new book so
that's cool
all right and so
okay so sh shea
says uh
if you want to just answer this quiz
questions thoughts on donna donda and
will you make a video on it have loved
all your kanye videos and so i'm still
kind of digesting the donda thing
because it's like two hours long that
album it's like who has time man you i
don't know so uh so i'm kind of
listening it to it in my spare time
trying to kind of wrap my head around it
i think that my first impression of it
is that it's
it's somewhat uneven let's say in terms
of an album some of the songs seem
unfinished and some of the songs are are
really good and so there are some that i
really like there's a song called heaven
and hell which i really like because it
has uh it has a kind of that militant
feeling about
you know about heaven and hell and about
the devil and everything i like that i
like that song a lot uh there's another
song called 24 which uses the uh you
know this kind of gospel choir feeling
uh which i also quite kind of like i
really like jesus's king a lot of people
said it wasn't
one of his best albums but i really i
actually really liked all the songs on
that album so
so those are the songs i like the most i
don't like i really struggle with this
like the the recent rap
you know noise making is the only thing
i can say and also the desire to reduce
the
reduce the bars you know like to have
to have each each each sentence be like
two words i really struggle with that so
it's hard for me to enjoy that i just
and i just gets on my nerves so i have
to say for now at least it's a it's a
it's a kind of 50 50. um and it and also
the the things that are said on the
album seem a little
kind of
less coherent let's say just just a
little bit all over the place so um yeah
so that's my that's my thing
um so uh hi does one properly name a
multi-headed beast that would be a hydra
that's usually how we called a
multi-headed beast
i mean i don't know if there's another
word for it i mean the chimera is the
usual
just word we use for
a beast that has different types of
heads you know
so eddie t why does a snake respond to
the music of the snake charmer
i think it doesn't is my understanding
is that it actually responds to the
movement of the flute and so it's it's
it's the movement of the flute which is
making the serpent sway
back and forth
and so um and so i think it's i mean
it's just basically fixing a moving
point um like
like a predator
and so i think that that's what that's
what is happening but if you want to
understand the symbolism let's say of
the idea of the music
the snake charming musician
it has to do with the idea that patterns
uh
solve animality and that pattern you
know this idea you know that uh was it
music calms the beast or whatever you
see different tropes of that
it has to it has to do with the idea
that that that patterns are what elevate
the world into consciousness you could
say and so through it i don't think it
actually these things actually work but
the idea that i think animals actually
don't hear the the patterns but the idea
let's say that the trope or the kind of
superstition around it is quite coherent
it's really the idea that through
through patterns you can actually you
can you can you can make something more
human or make something calm or bring it
into into the pattern and so uh you know
an example that of course is david who
who plays music for king saul and is
able to calm his
melancholy by playing music for him so
these patterns are healing
uh
healing king saul
so garner brothers asks what is the
symbolism of hollywood a city industry
that sells stories as products seems
there's something wrong with turning out
stories to meet a bottom line for
stories uh production companies invested
rather than letting stories arise
organically from the experience of
storyteller culture yes i mean for sure
there's definitely a problem with
hollywood in terms of what it is and
what it manifests it
it seems also in general that it's not
just about
storytelling there's also a whole idea
of storytelling which are leading us
towards
decadence are normalizing things which
which are not normal in uh in a regular
society
uh you know a kind of voyeurism where
you look at people's
private lives in way that that we're so
used to we think it's normal but but
that is actually uh somewhat perverse
ultimately um and so i'm not saying
there isn't anything good that can ever
come out of
of that you know and you know you've
watched some of my video movie critiques
where i've actually tried to point to
some of the positive things but i think
in general hollywood and the movie
industry and the music industry and all
these things participate in the problem
of
entertainment culture and the
transformation from participative
culture into this kind of passive
consumer culture which is which is
really deadly for the soul ultimately
especially if that's all you have you
know you can't live in these movies you
can't live in in uh you know a concert
is a passive
you these are not your songs right
they're their songs they're not your
stories it's their stories it's not the
things you can participate in so
ultimately that's what it's leading to
so samuel
asks hi jonathan hope you're well after
watching your interesting conversation
with uber boyo
i was thinking about christianity and
physical strength are there any good
places to look for christian inspiration
or guidance on being physically strong
or a protector
it does seem most writings are from
monks who although i appreciate that
they are battling demons and not exactly
considering the spiritual implication of
getting shredded or being a protector in
the way a warrior would need to be
is there a devotional aspect to exercise
physical activity in the christian
tradition do you know
anywhere to explore this idea in any
depth and so
um
yes
there is
there is at least
i unders i know it more in terms of the
west that is in the west they developed
a
a chivalric code
uh you know in which physical proudness
prowess and uh
you know capacity to accomplish certain
skills which were related to
combat to war uh we're seen as a way to
um
as a way to to let's say
accumulate honor
uh and then of course this honor would
be given to uh a woman would be given to
to your lady you know um and so that is
an interesting idea in terms of the
notion that that you receive honor and
then sacrifice it towards uh towards
those that can't do what you're doing
um
and so there definitely is a a general
aesthetic of the night and of the the
the the prowess of uh the physical
prowess of the night which i think is
there
i think that we have to be careful it is
a dangerous world to get into because it
is a world which is full of
which can lead you to pride just like a
lot of other things uh for sure i
struggle a little more with the getting
shredded part in the sense of you know
the the sense of
creating these these uh these bodies
that are really just uh aesthetic let's
say i struggle a little more with that
but you know who knows it's not i don't
think it's
it's not necessarily evil or anything i
just think it's maybe not as useful for
the spiritual life and i think that
physical discipline and and uh
exercise and a physical discipline can
be downstream from spiritual discipline
it can help you understand the
difficulty the sacrifice can help you
understand the you know the idea of
being drawn by purpose and focusing on
purpose
um you know and creating good habits all
of that i think can be useful to help
you understand what spiritual discipline
is so
you know saint paul himself uses the
image of an athlete you know of a race
and and all these images to talk about
the spiritual life you know which means
that and analogically you know there's
something in those practices which are
worthy of using as images for the
spiritual spiritual life
all right
so nelson justin evan i feel uneasy at
the prospect of secular food banks which
forbid mentioning religious affiliation
the secular food bank does what christ
asks feeding the hungry but they do it
in a way which does not recognize
christ's lordship just as judas tries to
sell the anointing oil to feed the poor
instead of using torture christ he's
giving aid to the homeless without
saying the aid is given in christ's name
an embodiment of antichrist typology
um
so the one thing that's important to
understand is that the kind of
helping the poor that christ talks about
um
is is has a lot to do with spiritual
realization
has a lot to do with with understanding
your own passions and then giving
yourself
to those that are smaller than you you
know uh in order to kind of participate
in this great pattern of god giving to
us you know and so
uh i think that that it happens very
much individually i don't think that i
think that it is completely fine to give
to the poor as an individual without
preaching to them i think that the
purpose is really
a lot of the purpose is for you when you
give to the poor yes of course you're
going to help the poor but a lot of it
is about you
being willing to give up you know your
riches willing to give up your surplus
willing to give up
um
you know and uh and give to the poor and
so
so i don't think you necessarily have to
preach them all the time now in terms of
secular food banks i mean i think i
think those are
how can i say this it's like
i think christian food banks are better
but if there aren't christian food banks
and i think secular food banks are are
are fine in the sense that when
non-christians do what christians should
do i think that that's good but like you
said of course
this is not a christian thing right and
so i think that
as christians we should give to people
in the name of christ and we should you
know and we should so christians if
there's a competition for christians to
have food banks
and uh
with non-christians you know and so
christians just need to rise up
just need to rise up to the challenge i
think and
and do it in a more loving way because
one other thing that that
qualifies
secular
charity
and this is something that i've
experienced living in africa for a very
long time
is that it's extremely um bureaucratic
and there's something about it which is
actually quite cold there isn't that
sacrifice self-sacrifice which
will which will be embodied by some nun
you know who lives in uganda and takes
care of children and has given up her
life in order to to help uh these
children
you know this is very different from the
ngo worker who has un money and then
delivers food to a village there's
nothing wrong with that but there's
definitely something lacking
in terms of
you know in terms of
seeing this help also as an act of
communion and of encountering christ so
so yeah
so
pkb5021 the symbolic view shows us that
we live in a narrative and to a certain
extent we reflect our experiences in the
narrative through stories paintings
poems how does
free will live within the context of the
symbolic view because sometimes it seems
no matter what you do
a particular narrative has to be
fulfilled i.e the death and rising of
christ and so like i said the the
freedom that we have is not a freedom
it's not a sorry there's mosquitoes in
my house it's not a freedom to do
whatever you want
that that is not what freedom is
right freedom is to
participate in the pattern in a way in
which you are going up the ladder you
could say which you're actually
being freed from the lower aspects of
the pattern as tyrants and
and and and you're moving up towards god
and so
you're right that's the pattern the
death and rising of christ the the the
pattern of everything is the pattern and
to a certain extent
you can't really change that and there's
no reason to want to
um
there is a place in there is a place in
this this whole pattern for idiosyncrasy
you know and uh and uh and idiosyncrasy
is a is is part of it uh but that's not
what we should really be attached to so
we shouldn't necessarily be attached to
the capacity we have for idiosyncrasy
and wearing a blue tie instead of a red
tie i mean that's fine whatever it's not
a not a big deal but that's obviously
not what true
uh freedom is um so
the story so david flores asked in the
story of saint george the dragon at
least the virgins i've heard
and depictions i've seen
there is an emphasis on piercing the
dragon's throat what is the symbolic
significance of this being the mortal
wound as opposed to the heat
or something else i'm not sure i
understand the idea of the heat well
usually the way that you see saint
george killing the dragon and also say
michael is that this is that they stick
the
the lance inside the mouth of the dragon
and so
you there's a lot going on there it has
to do with let's say fixing the lie
fixing the snake you know the head of
the dragon is the place of course
the head of anything is always the place
where the identity is it's always it's
it's one of the places let's say where
the identity is and so the idea of of
piercing through the mouth you know
piercing the head
you know through the face let's say um
has to do with that fixing the snake you
know stopping it from moving left and
right let's say
um so i think that that's what
that's what's going on there
all right so
all right so sorry i'm i'm really going
to skip people's second questions okay
i'm just going to do one per person
so phil hi jonathan happy to hear you're
on back on your feet joseph campbell
wrote that people have different
capacities for belief for conceptions of
god
even when they use the same name
campbell wrote that this is one of the
ironies of monotheism isn't it isn't
monotheism at all because everybody
believes in god in a different way is
this spinning hairs maybe it speaks to
christianity and other monotheistic
faiths ability to morph to incorporate
myths of many cultures or even different
beliefs and individuals so the way to
understand that is not it's not it
doesn't have to be that complicated it
doesn't have to be that controversial is
that god is beyond all
identities beyond all name is beyond all
definition is beyond all description
and so
then
from there
god fills up the entire
world fills up all of reality
and so what will happen is that then
there will be dogmas let's say the the
trinity there will be things which are
real and are really
uh a lower version of of a description
of god but nonetheless one which is real
and participates in how god fills up
reality uh and then there will be more
there will be let's say more
um
poetic versions where you hear people
sing in the psalms different
descriptions of god all of these will
participate in that and then there will
also be the way that you and
that you encounter god and that way will
be at least at the outset extremely
fragmentary extremely limited extremely
related to your own story in a way which
might which might make god look like not
much
uh but that that's because god fills up
the world and we encounter god in the
capacity that we have to encounter god
and so as we
come closer to god then god
then god let's say
self reveals himself reveals himself to
the person and then more
aspects more
deep a deeper version of what god's
revelation is will start to
connect to you and you'll start to have
a less
a less idiosyncratic a less you know
a bigger and fuller version of what god
really is and that can lead of course
to
to the highest to the highest and can
leave yeah be there so
um so yeah
all right so bluemix asked glad to have
you back i hope by the time you see this
you regain your taste and smell yes i
have
um
so what is the symbolism of pertaining
to the smearing and sprinkling of blood
on the altar after the pouring of the
blood on the earth
i have been thinking of them as
opposites but i'm not sure if that is if
that's a proper way of looking at them
my guess is that to do with the polarity
of heaven and earth i'm a little lost
though it really has to do with covering
you know and so
the the blood is like the life of the
being
and so it's and so it goes down
right and so the flesh
is the
is kind of more like the potential let's
say of the being and then that goes up
it's like a crossing and so part of the
going down is covering so you can
imagine blood covering the altar
covering the different holy things in
order to purify them you know um and so
that has to do with the higher element
of of being
coming down and covering in order to
in order to make it participate in that
higher part let's say um so
at least that's the way that i
understand it um
all right so king of the rat kings asked
what is the symbolism of profanity
particularly how modern languages tend
to place words related to things like
feces
um and sexuality
as profanity as opposed to archaic
profanities like in quebecois so what
the king of the rat kings is
is uh suggesting
uh is is because in
quebecois like the french canadian their
profanity or their swearing is
is all religious words
you know and you hear that in english
too people will say the name of of of of
christ will say the name of the mother
of god uh as a form of swearing as a
form of uh profanity um
and so that is definitely that's what it
is that's really a form of uh
of debasing you know
it has to do with the idea that
you know so i talked to you about the
idea of the
let's say the
the nakedness of of glory and the
nakedness of shame and it has to do with
what i talked about
in my video on uh this on the the mark
of kane
and so
it had to do with setting aside
so what happens is that there are two
aspects of setting aside there's an
asset of setting aside which is setting
aside above
right so
all the holy things and there's an
aspect of setting aside which is setting
aside to exclude
or to
bury you know you know the taboo part
let's say
um and so the setting aside above that
has to do with the religious words the
setting aside
let's say uh of shame
has to do with the
the all of the idea of feces and of of
of dirty versions of sexuality are using
using shocking words to describe sex and
to describe um describe the things that
you hide in shame the things that you
that you're not supposed to expose so
that's also why the words we use
as profanity
for sexual words are not
talking about procreation or about you
know a loving tender relationship with
your spouse but is a kind of vulgar
word which debases
the the basis sexuality that's why it's
profanity so it has to do with this
setting aside now what's fascinating
about about uh swearing is that it's
it's also it's taking that which is set
aside above
and bringing it down below
and so it's turning that which is set
aside for god and making it at the level
of set aside in the shameful side in the
shameful way and so that's what's going
on there that's why
in swearing you'll you'll both have
words that are about taboos and about uh
you know about excrement and things that
are that are supposed to be hidden
and about things that are supposed to be
hidden
in the holy things
um so that's what's going on there
that's why those both of those extremes
are used
to
to to let's say
express something beyond meaning express
something beyond rational meaning and
that's often what swearing is it's
something like
expressing an emotion which is beyond
meaning
beyond rational meaning and so it comes
out as these taboo words
expressing emotions which are too strong
expressing surprise expressing
frustration
uh all of this is the place where
swearing will will appear
and it's also filler
like
basic just filler non meaningless words
that people insert into sentences
because they can't hold their meaning
together let's say and so they have a
bad habit of putting in these filler
words that aren't actually meaningful
but but are what are taboo words
um
so
so hopefully i don't think i've ever
talked about this before so i think this
hopefully this will help you kind of
understand why swearing and profanity
why they look the way why they look the
way they do
um
all right so c s street soul
asks my wife recently became interested
in pretty gemstone the new age spiritual
movement and other cultures seem to have
an affinity for crystals gems and other
rare stones
sometimes the stones are perpetrated to
have magical healing properties the
ability to channel negative energy you
know away from positive energy towards
person or place and many other special
properties i scoffed at these claims
when i was materialists however i'm
trying to break out of my materials
framework and i recall the video you did
on dwarves where you briefly mentioned
rare stones
is this idea of using raw or polished
stones to affect the world the remnant
of primitive technology
how precious stones and gems fit into
one's home and into the christian
hierarchy in general
and so
for sure
stones
precious stones are really important
they're important in scripture and
they're used meaningfully
they're used in the uh
in the uh
now my mind is blank uh
the the vestment that the priest has he
had a square with stones in them and
that seems to be related to the casting
of lots and the to the divination
practices which existed in the old
testament and so it's not
it's not that material objects or that
especially precious ones especially
those that are light bearing you could
say that's what that's one of the
reasons why these stones are so
fascinating to people is that they're
stoned but they they shine right they
you see through them there they have a
kind of subtlety
which something like granite or you know
the more opaque stones don't have
uh
so for example like a really a really
kind of fascinating midrash that can
help you kind of understand the
difference is that in uh there are some
uh jewish midrash and traditions which
talk about how when moses
uh received the stones from god at the
outset there was like a a precious stone
right it was like a translucent
uh precious stone on which
god wrote the commandments and then
moses brought them down but the world
was not ready for them the world could
not accept it and there was no way to
connect the the that these stones with
the world and so moses broke them and
then when he wrote them himself on
stones then they were rougher stones
like like a you know like a marble or a
granite or um sandstone or something um
so it can kind of help you see that he
could also help you understand why the
new jerusalem is made out of these
stones now
having said that
the problem with a lot of this new age
stuff is that it's just made up
it's just made up people just make it up
like
who knows where all this stuff comes
from it's just kind of this thing it's
like they give these properties to these
stones and
i mean whatever
i i don't know where it comes from i
don't know what it is like i don't and
it's also a kind of weird materialism
it's not about meaning you know it's not
about let's say
um
you know the idea that let's say the
king would have certain stones which
would be attributed to him and that
would kind of participate in his glory
that kind of thing where there would be
the the the effect the stone would have
would be related to meaning it's uh it
really is about like these and these
weird energies that people talk about
a lot of and these you know a lot of
these new ages when they talk about
energies they really mean it in a like
in a scientific way like a wave particle
that is that that is kind of floating in
the air
and that you have to redirect or you
have to focus or you have to do all this
stuff and so a lot of the new weight
chef is just materialist nonsense and so
when you join with that some weird idea
about stones it just ends up being
i think it just ends up being a lot of
a lot of made up stuff it doesn't mean
that it can't sometimes work because you
know
belief is part of of reality and
you know placebos work so so if you have
something which is which is kind of
precious and which is beautiful and and
so it maybe it can have an effect on you
but i definitely wouldn't count on that
stuff like it's just
most of it is just
modern made up stuff
in my uh opinion so so sorry i don't
know if this is helpful but
all right so stephen wong says what is
the difference between protestants and
orthodox christians views on salvation i
mean that would be a very long
post and a very long answer i'm not sure
i could get through there but an easy
way for people to understand let's say a
little bit of the difference is that
let's say many protests and not all
products but many protestants really
focus on the idea of of a
substitution you know and an atonement
by substitution which is the idea that
that when adam sinned he kind of
infected humanity with sin
and that we deserve to die
uh and so the the sacrificial system in
the old testament was a way to
compensate for that was the way to offer
things instead of yourself because
you're supposed to die because you know
that god's anger was kind of
directed towards you to kill you and so
the idea is that god put all his anger
on christ and he is the substitution the
substitutional whatever uh sacrifice
and uh and that's how we are saved so if
we believe in that
then we are saved because we can enter
into that sacrifice
and uh so that's like
i mean like i said not all products
believe that but it's definitely a
a basic idea and that you're saved by
faith so you if you believe that if you
believe god believe that this sacrifices
is true then then you are saved by it
and so
orthodox really don't see salvation like
that at all they see salvation as a form
of healing a form of that that through
the sin of adam death entered into the
world and so we live in these bodies of
death which which are pulling us in
different directions you know because
you your body is in danger then you have
a propensity to sin because you can be
convinced that your desire to eat or you
desire for sex or your desire to protect
yourself is all-encompassing and so you
feel comfortable taking things from
others because you're doing it
to
to protect yourself or to to bolster
your your your dead life let's say
and that christ came to
assume human nature fill it up with his
presence um and that participating in
that through the sacraments through
communion through love of each other is
a healing process for
our life of death let's say so that's
what salvation is salvation is actually
healing from these passions from these
desires from these the slavery that we
have uh
you know with things of the world and
that the ultimate version of that is not
just to be
declared holy you're declared saved or
you know going to heaven when you die
but is really to become god through
participation to be united fully
to god to participate in his life to the
extent that that's possible uh and so
that's the ultimate goal of salvation is
theosis it's to become
to be united with god
um
all right so jay grubb says what is the
symbolism of the nose or smell in
general but also in the context of icons
saints often have thin noses a quote of
relevance maybe from the religion of the
apostles where father stephen deyoung
says that an off-repeated theme in
hebrews scripture that god is slow to
anger in hebrew idiom literally long of
nose this idiomatic phrase for patience
or long suffering is really reflected in
depiction of the saints with long noses
and traditional iconography
i don't understand the symbolic
association between patients uh and
having a long nose i guess this question
may be
of more immediate relevance given your
current loss of smell which i hope you
get back soon but that makes me think uh
is the loss of smell from kobe symbolic
anything all right so
um
so the importance of smell for example
is very important because
smell is
you could say something like smell is
the closest thing to a spiritual sense
that we have
in the idea that
smells
are you can't touch them you can't see
them you can't hear them they are ex
pure experiences
uh
and so
there's a sense in which like you know
we burn the incense and the smoke this
air the smells are contained in the air
so the air goes up
and the air is smelled by god or the the
the
sacrifice even of the meat you know the
the meat sacrifices were smelled by god
because it's the spiritual part of it
which goes up and it's it's air
basically and so the idea of this this
capacity to perceive air
is what smell is and so that's why it is
related to
to kind of the spiritual sense um
so the idea of uh of uh of there's also
another aspect which is which is uh
a little more immediate which is that
the nose is the highest point on your
face and so it's the furthest
it's the furthest
from your whole face it's like the
summit of your face you could say and so
there's something about that as well
which is related to its spiritual
quality of smelling of being able to
to um
let's say to perceive the spirit right
to perceive air perceive the invisibles
um but it's a very intuitive it's not a
rational it's it's pre-rational or super
rational let's say
and so that's as much as i understand
now why is it related to patience
something that i would think about
because i'm not sure i totally
understand that and yes there are some
people that that understand that saints
and icons have longer noses i feel like
some some iconographers overdo it a
little bit
because
i think sometimes it has it shouldn't be
a caricature but um but yes some people
do definitely in their icons make the
saints noses a little longer in order to
uh to show that that they're that they
are becoming similar to god
so
mfpr
says as an icon cover and participate
when participation of icons in everyday
life secure life would you
what participation of icons in everyday
secular life would you recommend some
people create a corner in their home for
an altar like structure others like in
my tradition
are more in the one icon per room to
spread the force field camp i feel a bit
uneasy about mixing sacred and profane
should you watch netflix nights to an
icon so i think i would say just follow
your tradition you know it's there the
russians really have this tradition of
the home altar or the the bright corner
let's say
um but like you said it's not
necessarily a universal practice and
there are people for example like there
are people who say things like you
shouldn't have
if you're a married couple you should
have icons in your room because
you know that's where things happen and
then there are other traditions that say
the very opposite you say you should
have an icon of the mother of god and of
christ in your bedroom if you're a
married couple to kind of remember the
chastity of your of your wedding um and
so
i don't think there's a problem with
mixing the sacred and the profane that's
for sure like
in in constantinople they were
sorry
there would have been icons everywhere
on the walls you know on the coins you
know the idea that you would have icons
on coins you have the image of christ on
actual coins and you would have them on
buildings uh as much
the the the church buildings as the um
as the uh the profane buildings but
obviously you need to have them placed
in a
in uh in a position of honor in a
position of respect you don't want to uh
to have them on the floor or have them
you know in in a in a kind of lowly
discarded place you want them to be in a
place of honor so it just really depends
on your um
i would say depends on your tradition
and uh
but i wouldn't be afraid of mixing
sacred and profane if you if you have a
proper hierarchy
um
all right so we're done with the
website let's go
there's only one question on subscribe
star so let's do that
um
so xrd says hi jonathan glad you're over
the hump
since you're still recovering i'll give
you an easy one what's a topic you never
get asked about
but wish you would
it's interesting i don't i don't think i
have a good good answer for that
i really like the question and answers
because
because i often am surprised about the
questions and it forces me to say things
that i've never
said before that i didn't think were
important
and so you know
like for example like just that question
about profanity it's not something that
i would necessarily have made a video
about but then once i'm talking about it
i'm thinking yeah you know what actually
this is important and i understand why
people would be curious about this and
so uh so uh so i don't necessarily have
a have an answer for you
all right so let's start on patreon now
dan diego de la vega
nice hope you recovered well mate and
your family's okay too thanks everybody
by the way thanks for all the wishes
everybody i really appreciate and i know
a lot of people were praying for me
that's you know i'm very
i feel very touched by that so
so my question is regarding the lord is
my shepherd prayer what is the symbolic
meaning behind the part of the prayer
that says your rod and your staff
they comfort me
specifically the rod and the staff
hmm
it
it probably has to do this is this is me
improvising now because i never thought
about this
i think it might have something to do
with the right hand and the left hand
in the sense that the staff
is has to do with identity
you know um right there's a story where
you know tamar
takes judah's staff as a token of his
identity
the idea of the staff of the king or you
know the the scepter of the king
i think staff has to do with like this
kind of verticality and and um
and identity
and i think that the rod
at least my understanding is that at
least a rod is often if that's what it
says in scripture right spare the rod
spoil the child the idea that the rod is
probably more for
punishment um
and so you would have the right hand and
the left hand in the sense of you would
have this kind of
authority which which comforts you which
you know that the shepherd is there for
you you can see him from far away with
the staff you can you can understand
that he's there to lead you uh but you
also have uh the rod which may be not
necessarily maybe not necessarily used
against the sheep but may be used
against the wolves too right this idea
of a capacity to
to have some kind of uh hostile or more
aggressive
behavior let's say so
that's the way that i see that but i
might be completely wrong but at least
that's my understanding
so jason lindsay says hey jonathan hope
your recovery is going well
in the lord of spirits podcast they talk
about the notion that the reason fallen
angels cannot repent as well as the
reason man was made for moral
was made mortal for sinning is because
having an immortal body somehow prevents
one from repenting
i'll be interested in hearing your
thoughts on this and perhaps an answer
as to why an immortal can change in one
direction from unfallen to fallen but
not the other
um
it's definitely something that i don't
think i've completely wrapped my head
around um
it has to do with change right it has to
do with that's what death is so death is
the capacity
to change whereas
the idea of the
angels
falling
you know i've read some place where they
say things like as soon as the angels
were created they fell
right in the sense that they're not
participating in time in the same way
that we are and so they they kind of
take their position on the hierarchy in
the direction that they're taking
um
and so that's probably the best way to
to uh understand that
but like i said i don't think i totally
understand for sure i understand more
the idea of
that's that's the that's why god made us
die that's what god that's why we have
death in our lives is because death is
an ancient agent of transformation and
that the the capacity to die
uh can become a kind of progression you
know by which
things are
refined you know in your life and you
you you're able to change
uh so g garcia do you think every
technology is waiting to participate in
the divine or will there have to be some
degree of renunciation
as someone going to school for
accounting do you have any tips
on how to submit these technologies to
higher principles
um
and so i think you'll definitely
there'll be some kind of
renunciation because the whole image of
christ talking about the end of times
has to do with the wheat and the chaff
and that there is an aspect of reality
which is chaff and which will
be burned off and there's an aspect of
it which is useful and something like
seed or something like
you know the useful part of the world
which will be gathered together into the
silo gathered together into the into the
new jerusalem and so i think that that's
the best way to uh
to understand that
and so you know how any tips on how to
submit these technologies to higher
principles i think that
there's no secret to it it's there's no
the tip is to
always
under always remember that these tools
are your to our tools that these
technologies are tools they are not the
purpose which is something which
shouldn't seem obvious to us but they're
not
because we we actually act very often as
if the technologies were the purpose
themselves with the goal themselves and
so you know as long as technology
remains a tool which is
used for good obviously you can use
tools for bad
then you're in less danger but it's hard
to do because
these tools have their own
attention
attention grabbing mechanisms you could
say especially the internet and
especially you know the kind of screen
technology so
so charlie longoria says hello jonathan
i've been wondering about the symbolism
of the skull i don't know how it is in
canada but the police and military in
the u.s have adopted the punishers call
as their unofficial logo
should this be something
should this be something to be worried
about i never really i i don't think
i've ever seen that with police
uh and military you know so
i mean the scholar is just an idiot and
a skull is an image of death it's a it's
an image of uh
of death and so
the skull that is used by on a heavy
metal t-shirt and let's say the skull
that is
represented on the monk's schema you
know on the on the uh
it has to do with uh with death and so
for sure
the the punisher skull is is a
frightening one because it's
it's not it's punisher is acting like
the angel of death that's how he
perceives himself and so
the idea that skull is something like a
sign of the angel of death or that this
person is a purveyor of death
um and so
i've seen people use that like kind of
these kind of
edgy you know whatever edgy guys with
their jeeps and their
motorcycles or whatever but i don't
think i've ever seen uh police and
military use that which is odd because
obviously punisher is uh
is a
uh is not a in the authority structure
you know he he's a vigilante he's a
yeah
so
matt turjan
hi jonathan when jesus said john the
baptist was elijah when the pharisees
asked john the baptist if he was elijah
he said no
was john hiding his identity from the
pharisees
or did he really not know
that is definitely a really interesting
kind of aporia which is presented in
scripture
um
and so
maybe the best way to kind of understand
that is that it was it was christ's
prerogative to name him
and that
john would not have named himself
and so
that's why he would say no when he was
asked but that christ had the capacity
to
to name him
so
that's the best way i understand that
so nicola alexik
christ conquered death by death what do
we make of conquest as a concept
understanding must conquer our own soul
for hearts through prayer fasting and
confession but does it really stop there
at the internal level
um
i mean i think that
there are ways to conquer which are
acceptable like to conquer a sphere to
conquer a sphere of activity
in the sense of matter
the sense of mastering it
there's definitely this uh this idea
um
but i
i think that at least in the christian
vision
that
christians should not
conquer other nations to conquer them
and that
this is when it's happened in history
it's always seen or often presented as a
as in another manner to try to
hide or mask the fact that they're
conquering for example
if you look at you know the whole
history of colonization it was never
presented as a form of conquering it was
always presented as a form of help as a
form of supporting the person's people
there
and so you can kind of see the problem
of these christian
and so
so i think that that's the best way to
understand that you know christian
christian
war
was often done you know
in defense rather than in conquering
mean that it always happened that way
doesn't mean that it will always happen
that way but there is an there is a way
in which
conquering for conquering you know is
the missing of the of the mark
so
you know
but you also have to
understand something like taking back a
land that had been taken from you is
something that christians i think have
accepted very much so and so for example
the crusades were not viewed as
conquering the crusades were viewed as a
retaking of that which had been
taken from us or reestablishing of the
original
of the original limits let's say
all right so mark kalashnikov says hello
jonathan can you please explain the
correlation the iconographic depictions
of an of an angel the right and the left
hand on either side of christ more so
how it relates to other similar
depictions usually in red and blue
garments
elijah and moses martha and mary adam
and eve peter and paul theotokos and the
forerunner and you've covered aspects of
this previously but looking at many
icons it seems to be a very strong
recurrence in a lot of images
i was wondering if you had any other
insights yes i mean i you just have to
understand all of these
as different aspects of the right hand
and the left hand of christ or different
aspects of the two
extremes you know
the two extremes that manifest
themselves as being united by christ and
so
when you see characters that are facing
each other
in this kind of duality
you have to see them as complementary
right so you can understand you know
elijah and moses for example so elijah
is a prophet at the end of the world
moses is the prophet at the beginning of
the world
you know moses brings the law
you know elijah is facing uh
a corrupt
uh corrupt israel
uh you know moses uh there there are
many there moses let's say uh
has it's more in related to the system
or the like the law and the system of
sacrifice and all of that whereas elijah
is more about the fire right the fire
coming down and a more
kind of wild mystical aspect of his of
his of his life you know he stays in a
cave and eats meat brought to him by
crow which is very very
shocking right because crows are
scavengers crows eat dead flesh and so
like the symbolism of elijah in that
time of famine in that time when the
world is falling apart being kept secret
in the cave while everything is while
the world is ending basically
is a very very
kind of profound and uh
and disturbing symbolism you know and
you can compare it to let's say moses
who was kept in the basket on the water
uh and was brought to to the the
to the princess to the egyptian princess
whereas elijah was kept in a dark cave
and and like i said
eight eight uh scavenged meat so
so that's what you have to understand it
so you look at peter and paul you look
at their at their how they are facing
each other how they are
complementary how their opposites uh
adam and eve the same
and uh
yeah et cetera et cetera like the mother
of god and saint john is very you can
just see it right there right so the
mother of god is pure she's covered she
she and according to her tradition she
was hidden in the temple as a young
woman she's a
and uh and she's quiet you know her true
her tradition is private and her
influence is private whereas xinjiang
the foreigner he's out in the desert
he's screaming he's telling everybody to
repent he's wearing garments of skin
he's got you know crazy hair crazy beard
and uh he gets his head cut off you know
so
you can really see like you could just
really see these two these two extremes
uh manifesting themselves so
all right so hi jonathan
hope you're well my question uh dusan
babic asks but
my question is about deuteronomy 12 23
but be sure you do not eat the blood
because the blood is the life and you
must not eat the life with the meat
what is the meaning of blood here how's
blood life or soul in some translation
and why is
why is eating it prohibited
i mean
it's the life in the sense that it's
it's that which moves from the center
into the periphery right
it's that which goes into the heart and
then moves out of the heart and goes out
into all the flesh
and so it's like uh it's like a water
the water above this the flowing water
you could say you know the idea of
flowing water in scriptures is like an
influence of heaven whereas static water
or bitter waters is the lower part of
that equation
and so blood because it's flowing
because it moves from the the heart from
the center to the periphery and then
goes back and carries let's say life
um
that's why it's the soul of the body
it's it's the soul of the flesh let's
say
um
so as for the rest you know you can
refer to the other question i answered
which is which was already kind of
dealing with that a little bit
so matthew mulbrandon asks
i watch your old videos on space and
time counteracting each other when you
were flooded much of that your
geographic symbolism has revolved around
borders centers walls edges order chaos
what are one or two ways
network spaces and times
alter or fit into space and time
patterns
of obliteration and control in the
symbolic world and stories what
all right so let's let's let's he says
just to clarify my question i what i
meant by network i put a definition
below a network is defined as nodes and
edges and often has a hierarchy of
importance in academia so an airport
that acts as a hub to exchange patchers
that are going to other places is a
large node the flight paths are edges
the elite church was networked as
it only controlled small spaces in a
wider pagan world this q a network it
exists in virtual space and time and is
a hub
so
what are one or two ways network spaces
and times alter fit into space and time
patterns of obliteration and control
in the symbolic world stories i'm not
sure i totally understand what you mean
patterns of obliteration
and control
ah sorry man i don't totally understand
what you what you mean and so
maybe i can give you some hint of what i
understand of what you're saying i'm not
sure i totally get it and so imagine you
have a network like you're saying
uh you have a a network structure which
has these hubs and these edges which are
the connection between
let's say the center or the top of the
the reason for the hub or the the place
where it all culminates and then
the branches where it goes and so you
can understand that
there are aspects of the world which are
not connected to that hub and those
aspects of the world which are not
connected to that hub are are something
like potential to the network
and so the network
by connecting itself to further out in
quantity
can increase its control
integrate the potential of the world
into its network uh
structure right and so that's how the
church works too right the church
let's say you know has these bishops
then these bishops have other bishops
and then these other bishops have
priests and then you you kind of have
this network and then at some point
someone goes out and found another
church and then connects that to the
bishop
uh and then on and on and so the tree or
the network can spread out
and uh and fill up more and more space
and have more control over more
more space um
so that's that's as much as i can give
you like i said i'm not sure i totally
understand your question
all right so manuel montiel says my
question uh says hi jonathan praying for
your continued recovery my question
surrounds the highly polarizing coping
vaccine mandates making waves
in the west in your april 2020 q a you
answer a question centering on this in a
in a great way control 666 the
accounting for everything but ended your
response within essence uh to be
determined
remark that when things begin to play
out you'd have to be more explicit about
your response well it seems like those
things are beginning to play out that
being what are your thoughts on the fact
that it's becoming clear the vaccine
will determine who's included and
excluded from society yes
yes i mean you're right and that's why
i'm supposed to make this mark of the
beast vaccine
mark of the beast video and that i
haven't totally done it because
the kind of thing that'll get me banned
from youtube in part and it's also the
kind of thing which will cause
controversy in my own
church and hierarchy but i i think
you're right i think that the fear that
i had which is that the vaccine
would be used as a as a way to account
for those that are inside and then
exclude people uh from the participation
society it seems like that is
definitely on the horizon and it's
happening here
um
and the obsession with vaccinating
everybody like the the the obsession
with having with vaccinating now
children
vaccinating you know 0 to 12 and 12 to
16 and and
is just to show that that there's
something
that's not rational which is going on
there's something which has to do with
the desire to have something in which
everybody participates to have a kind of
sacrament
in which everybody participates which
also has the advantage
of creating a scapegoat
for those who don't a scapegoat for the
disease itself which is already
happening
a scapegoat uh
for whatever it is you're going to want
to make
go wrong or you're going to want to
notice that goes wrong
will be able to be blamed on those that
don't want to participate in this
sacrament so for example
if they don't reopen if they keep saying
that you have to wear masks
if they
if they
do another lockdown if they all of this
will now be easily blamed
on the
scapegoats
and no matter what the facts are it
doesn't matter anymore none of these
things matter anymore it's just going to
be a narrative
scapegoating which will reinforce
the feeling that people who are
vaccinated and have this interior
passport that's coming
are good citizens that they're part of
society that they and they also have
a group that they can um
that they can despise so
it definitely looks like we're moving
towards
towards 666
and mark of the b symbolism i don't
think we're there yet i i don't think
that
because in scripture it says that
that it will be a kind of apostasy and i
i'm not sure i see that yet like i don't
see that it's an apostasy
to be uh vaccinated unless people take
the idea that some of these vaccines
contain uh aborted cell lines
cell lines from aborted children
i don't think it's it's an explicit uh
form of apostasy so for me it's not
there yet but it's like you can see the
system taking shape and you can kind of
see it coming together so for example
like if they make the coveted passport
necessary to go to church
we will have reached another threshold
like it's going to be a serious
threshold and i can kind of see it on
the horizon at least here in quebec i
can see it coming so um
yeah
okay
so adam vanya asks hi jonathan my dad is
the last catholic who has recently been
trying to rediscover his faith i would
like to get him a bible for his birthday
this year but i'm not sure what to
purchase
um he has mentioned wanting a book that
features commentary and other
translations of words included
can you recommend any
good study bibles
um yeah there's i mean obviously there's
the orthodox study bible which is good
you know it's good it's pretty good
there is also um so susan martin wrote a
comment uh suggesting the new uh word on
fire bible which i haven't seen so i
don't know
i don't know what it looks like it's
actually beautiful like it's well it's
well made and so those are two
two examples
that um
that you can look at
so dionysus says oh jonathan do you have
any thoughts or reading recommendations
preferably from the christian tradition
regarding the distinction between
information belief knowledge
and wisdom
i'm afraid i'm afraid nothing comes to
mind at the moment so if i think of
something before the end of the q a i'll
tell you
all right so anonymous says hi jonathan
hope you're recording well could she
music be understood as a way to
symbolically box in the flowing or
cosmic time nature of music
it's an arranged music score with all
its formalities or even choreography
more representative causing space in
this regard as opposed to free-form folk
music for example i think there's
definitely something going on there i
think there's something in the general
desire to document
uh and to uh
you know the ancient uh let's say forms
of notations in
in uh for music were very vague they
were really about going up going down
like i'm not a music musical expert but
they're very vague and so the movement
towards
a fixing of musical notation the moving
towards uh recording
um
definitely affects one of one of the
realities of music which is this
kind of
this kind of free-flowing
structure and this and this thing which
kind of
changes but also carries pattern in a
more immediate and
and uh
internal way because the ancient
musician would have had to kind of
internalized these patterns
um just like an ancient poem poet would
internalize these patterns and then
would be able to
do something like improvise or to adjust
and to move things around so
all right so student martin says i'm
curious what do you think of the
dormition of the mother of god in the
orthodox tradition
and how it compares to the assumption of
marrying the catholic tradition are they
basically the same thing or are they
symbolic differences according to the
catholic catechism and the doctrine of
the immaculate conception mary was
conceived without original sin and so
did not experience corruption of the
body at death
catholic belief was taken body and soul
into heaven at the end of her life since
since i firstly come from a catholic
background i'm interested in cultivating
a deeper understanding of the dermation
of the mother of god thank you so
so there's a few things here the first
thing is that the orthodox don't don't
need the doctrine of the immaculate
conception because we don't believe
anybody is born with original sin
so so we don't need that doctrine
we have the idea that we do believe that
the mother of god did not sin but she
doesn't have to have this special tag
about her
in order to describe her
now in the in the story on which the the
door mission and the assumption is based
you really do see the assumption of the
mother of god you see it in the text of
the story so i think that it is um
that it is
there
the reason why i think it's not shown in
the iconography
often sometimes it is actually it it
happens it's not it's but it's not the
usual way
uh i think it has to do with something
like uh like the mystery of of
the mystery of the final moment like the
mystery of of the resurrection or the
mystery of the body because the the
we we as orthodox we understand that
what the mother of god went through
is something like
what ultimately we will all participate
in
um
so there is a mystery there
i think that the reason why
the the falling asleep or the dimension
of the mother of god is more prominent
also in orthodoxy is that
it also represents a kind of full cycle
with the end
it represents kind of like the end of
the of the world right the the kind of
the end of this whole cycle the end of
the body you could say
um and it also coincides with the end of
the liturgical year and it's often
represented on the back of the church in
the western where the sun goes down so
you can understand the dormition of the
mother god as the setting of the sun
and the end of uh of a cycle
and so i think that that's probably one
of the reasons why
one of the many reasons why the orthodox
emphasizes dormition
uh explicitly far more than they do the
uh the assumption part let's say
so anton
ol anderson says hello jonathan glad
you're back you're one of the few signed
voices in our confusing time well thank
you anton that's very touching and very
kind of you um
i have a question regarding the
eucharist it is traditionally received
at church but christ doesn't mention
priests as the only one who can
consecrate and officiate the eucharist
in john 6 christ seems to suggest that
anyone can eat his flesh and drink his
blood
has the church falsely claimed authority
over the eucharist do we all have the
authority and could be united in christ
separately or would it in fact be a sin
and missing the point to partake at home
on our own
the question has puzzled me for some
time and i wonder how christ actually
intended for us to drink his blood and
eat his flesh and practice
well i think it's really important to
understand
that christ
reveals the eucharist although he does
say that to the crowd in john 6
but he reveals the mystery of what that
means
in presence of the apostles only in a
private space in a closed-off space not
in the open so there is a sense in which
the eucharist is a is a mystery
of
of the of the inner circle let's say
and that is the way that it was always
understood by christians
and it's and it's the way that it's
still practiced today which is that
the eucharist is the mystery of the
church it is the hidden
aspect of christianity and so in the
early centuries
it seems like catechumen those who were
wanting to become christian because they
heard the gospel and heard
and and knew something enough about
christ to be attracted to him
that they would actually not be told
about the eucharist until after they
were baptized that it was something of a
secret
uh because because it's we it's very
scandalous it's extremely scandalous and
so we're used to it because we've had it
for 2000 years but it's like it's a very
scandalous
uh symbolism
and so
it is it is kind of kept in the mystery
um
and so in terms of the idea that priests
are the one who could consecrate and
officiate the eucharist i think that
that also is something which stems
really from the very beginning
which is something like christ
did this
ritual with the disciples
and then the disciples
are the ones who perpetuated that
and then the disciples gave the
authority to to who they wanted to
continue to perpetuate this mystery in
the church and then that is
the apostolic section that is the that
is the descendants of the disciples
training their
replacement
to
to officiate the mysteries of the of the
church
um
and so so yeah
you know and and uh you know you always
have to remember that it's like although
it is christ says that like that there's
also
uh saint paul also
as it's saint paul christ himself who
talks about you know that if you do not
recognize the body of christ then you
are then you're eating and drinking to
your to your condemnation that is that
it is a dangerous thing taking the
eucharist is dangerous and should not be
given to anybody because if you don't
recognize the body of christ in which
you're participating
then it's like a curse on you um
as as dangerous as that i remember i
remember an orthodox priest when i was a
catechism and you know people would come
up to the chalice once in a while and
they were orthodox and then he would ask
them are you orthodox and they would say
no
um and then he would always say i'm not
gonna give you communion
right and and the reason why i'm not
going to give you communion because i
want to protect you i want to protect
you from this
because if i give you communion it's
dangerous to you
and so
um
all right so tyrone
tyrone camilleri says ask the same
question asked about uh the difference
between the symbolism of their mission
and the
assumption um
so yes i think i answered that so sorry
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna answer it uh
again
um i think that that that the idea of
the assumption of the virgin in in
orthodoxy is a kind of tacit or
or hidden or or or less vocal tradition
it's just not it's definitely not a
dogma that's for sure it's just a
it's a it's a pious tradition of the
church so enrico says hi jonathan how
did ancient world scripture think of
consciousness and subconscious minds
before freud
how did we make a distinction between
them is it something like heart moose
versus flesh and mind or did they have a
different perspective of persons
architecture altogether
uh so
and so yes yes they had the idea that
that the soul or the or the person had
different hierarchy of mind
and that that we had a rational mind but
we also had a
a kind of irratible part of us and we
had a
more passionate aspect of us
uh and in those
in those parts of the person is what we
would call something like unconscious
you know in the sense that they are
these desires that pull us
these thoughts that appear to us uh you
know these emotions that come to us and
we don't control them
completely and they they seem to kind of
arise out of these dark places
um
all right so marcus david asked to get
asked about the mark of the beast and
everything's i think i answered where i
think about that anders vrolstad asks
hey jonathan
is there an overall pattern symbol of
saint peter there's much going on with
him and i cannot see how it holds
together he is for instance known for
being a fisherman being a rock denied
jesus crucified upside down striking
priests with swords and holding the keys
to heaven
the symbolism of the same peter is very
coherent it's uh it's it's quite
coherent actually
um
[Music]
you know he's he is
maybe i should make a video about it
because i i realized that that i could
explain it but it's going to take a it
is definitely going to take a while
um
but but he there is a duality to saint
peter
there's also duality to saint paul
you know a lot of symbol a lot of
symbolism or a lot of characters in
scripture always have a two sides to
them and so saint peter is one of those
which is why
there's a relationship between him being
the first being the rock being the one
who walks on water
and the one who denies christ you know
as well
so
so uh yeah so let me let me
let me consider making a video about the
symbol of saint peter
sorry
joe kelly o'neil says god you're feeling
better jonathan okay so i'm getting used
to thinking symbolically and i can't
tell if this is an easy question or a
doozy of a question
what is the symbolism behind the
inversion
invention of birth control at the
societal level
i mean it it has it has to do with a
fragmentation of things and so you know
sexuality has many logi has many
purposes
and the the the invention and kind of
spread of birth control is a way in
which the world is breaking apart which
is that we're taking aspects of
sexuality
and we're breaking them apart from each
other and so we have an idea that there
is
baby-making and then there's sex and
that those two are actually kind of
separate from each other
um
and that that that sexuality is more to
do with personal expression and and
pleasure and all of that
so
so that's what it is and what it's going
to do is very simple which is what is
happening is that it just makes society
sterile
and it makes uh society obsessed with
pleasure and move towards idiosyncrasy
and pleasure as well so
so janet horseman says greeting from
minneapolis epicenter of woke george
floyd first patron saint of the new
religion is venerated in many a church
here whoa
it's disturbing one of their newest
doctrine is getting the code vaccine is
the best way to show cruciform love
love willing to lay down your life to
your neighbors right now what is the
right way to respond to this
the best way to respond to this is very
simple is that if that is true
then
i don't think it's true
but
if that is true
then love and late willing and laying
down your life is something which can
only happen
voluntarily fully voluntarily
and if you do it because you have
pressure from the government and because
you have pressure from your employee and
because you have pressure to get a
covered passport and you have pressure
to to participate in society and you do
it because everybody's doing it and
because you'll be excluded if you don't
do it
then all of that nonsense goes away
and that it has nothing to do with
self-sacrificial love
because self-sacrificial love is not
imposed from from authority
so
yeah
all right so brett says howdy from the
lone star state what does the seven
miracles perform by jesus in the book of
john symbolize dude you can't ask
questions like that
okay here we go also you could touch on
the symbols of each miracle water to
wine healing your own soul these are how
can you ask these questions you can't
ask me to interpret every single
every single miracle that christ does in
the gospel of john
in a question in a q a
so
i'm sorry i don't think this is gonna
happen
uh
all of christ all of christ
all of christ miracles are the same they
are showing how christ
heals the world fills the world uh
it has power over the world
you know
is the one who created the world and so
that's what you see with the water to
wine
healing the roman soldier's son is
definitely important because it also
shows christ as the top of the hierarchy
and as capable of
acting from afar in the hierarchy you
know like what is it that the the the
roman soldiers tells christ about how
that he has a roman soldier tells us it
tells his soldiers to do things and his
will goes down the hierarchy and he's
able to act you know outside of
immediate action and so it kind of shows
how and then christ says you know
something like you know the the faith of
this man or whatever something about the
faith is man
um
and so
to all of that paralyzed man at the pool
it's the same the transformation of um
in the pool itself this idea of the
transformation of of static water into
moving water right the the raising of
the water from above in order for it to
kind of flow down is what that what
happens uh
happened there but then christ shows
that he is you know
directly doing that so i think that's
enough like i'm not going to go into
every single one of them um
so uh but you know who knows maybe you'd
be interested in uh
it'd be interesting to do to do more
about miracles if that interests you
so gr says jonathan do you have any
thoughts on the symbol symbolism of
liminal spaces i see them as haunted
places of transition time of christ
crisis following some kind of loss but
ahead of an incumbent judgment i can
help but to picture them in my mind as
the ant room to the place where the holy
grail is located
seem to be quite prevalent in the modern
world especially during these weird
times um
and so i'm not sure what you mean you
mean you see liminal spaces
like haunted places or places that are
not places um
like places of transition like uh like
alleyways like uh
so i'm not sure i totally understand
what you mean by liminal spaces um
yeah
so i don't know
you know i mean if you mean like haunted
places for sure usually haunted places
have to do with things which aren't
resolved which are left lingering and so
because they're left lingering they have
they leave residues and so so in that
sense a liminal space like that let's
say somewhere where
a violent crime happened and then we'll
leave and then because it's something
which happened and isn't resolved let's
say then it will leave residues
and those residues can be experienced as
uh
as a kind of haunting because
yeah because because things that haven't
been closed up
so maybe that's a interesting way to
understand that
white lawrence what is the symbolism of
spongebob squarepants within five years
of his premiere it exploded into pop
culture icon
perhaps the most
famous children show of all time and i
wonder if there is symbolic significance
in the show's premise
or is it a mistake to assume that
because something is a staple pop
culture even for a long time it has
symbolic richness i've never really
watched square bob squarepants whatever
spongebob squarepants i was too old
anyways but
it seems to me that it has to do with
absurdity
and the you know the laughter which
comes from absurdity and so a lot of the
tropes a lot of the characters are
absurd
you know uh
what is it bikini bottom or whatever the
name of the city is you know you can
totally understand what's going on it's
all about the bottom of the ocean and
the bottom of the waters and how it's
all crazy and nonsensical and upside
down and
and uh and absurd and so i think that's
what it's that's what it's about it's
about the absurd and of course the
absurd is funny
and so and so that's why it's so
that's why it's so popular with kids
that's my at least that's my
interpretation now whether or not they
are in the story some kind of symbolic
structure i don't know because i haven't
really i haven't really watched it so
sorry
hi jonathan can you please explain the
symbolism of behind the warning moms
tell their children about never being
able to whistle as adults if they don't
eat their bread crust as kids i've never
heard that i've totally never heard
that
at all
it's interesting
right because the crust of on bread of
course is the
is the limit right it's like a hard
shell which protects the rest the bread
that is exposed to elements it's all
that
um
and whistling is obviously this kind of
pure kind of musical
sound that you make through by breathing
out of your just by breathing just by
blowing out of your mouth um
so there's definitely something there
there's definitely some kind of
connection in terms of opposites but uh
i don't totally i never heard that so i
don't totally totally get it
um
so david luters asks
anyways my question
is what is your family familiarity
opinion on the resurgence of
intellectual life in conservative
circles
figures in mind are william craig john
piper tim keller the discovery institute
and particularly craig is a prominent
re-insured reintroducing the
intellectual viability of christianity
in the cultural milieu what do you think
of his aim in particular and how does
christian intellectual gender relate to
the symbolism of totalizing orders
um
so
i'm not a big fan of these guys to be
honest like i'm sorry to say
william lane craig
his type of argumentation is just so far
from mine it's just so completely far
from mine
there i don't feel in william lane craig
i feel like he argues for the existence
of god as a kind of you know ultimate
cause and a kind of necessary
combination of creation into a point you
know of origin
um
but i don't see him i don't see and any
of these people i don't see the idea of
the the story of christ or the story of
scripture or the revelation of christ as
being something which fills up the world
and
and and shows us makes us participate in
in the pattern of reality and so because
of that i
i find them not super interesting um
sorry to say
so the wakeful azir jonathan are the
chaotic waters below
that you recently mentioned the same
underworld that dante describes it so
why does the latter have space and
structure
uh and so no they're not the same
the
the the underworld the upside down
hierarchy of underworld
um
is more like the corruption of identity
it's more like the corruption of the
hierarchy and so
it's not just chaos
but it's rather
identities which are not in their proper
place is the best way to understand it
and so let's say desires that are
all consuming
and are not in their proper order so
because of that they end up creating an
upside-down hierarchy
because of because of their nature as
being fragmentary and then taking up all
your attention
you know kind of like woke
upside down hierarchies you know this is
the same as the kind of hierarchy the
upside-down hierarchy of hell where
these passions take up
attention or take up
cosmic space take up cosmic attention
and so they they end up laying
themselves out in a
in a system where you're moving down
towards
you know the
the worst sin let's say which which in
dante at least is a betrayal
so so it's different
so ulysses b
celio says why eve came from a rib what
does the symbolism mean
is it that women cause always a little
discomfort
and i think it i've talked about this
often it has to do with the fact that
the way the best way that i understand
it it has to do with the idea that eve
came from his side i like that
name word better than rib
like so it's like
the the ver let's say the eve was you
can imagine like a being cut in half
like
a part a party it's like it's cut and
now it becomes male and female that's
that's really the best way that i
understand it um
and also the idea that that she came
from his side means you know saying john
chrysostom has this idea that
that the reason why eve came from adam's
side was because
if she had come out of his head he would
have she would have dominated over him
she had come out of his feet then he
would have dominated over her but that
god made her to be an equal and a helper
and therefore he took her from
uh adam's side
uh and so that's another way to kind of
understand that in terms of why she came
from his side rather
than
something else so
jason gotta waltz says what is the dark
knight of the soul
um
and so the dark knight of soul obviously
refers to saint john of the cross and a
catholic mystic who spoke about
the descent into death you could say and
there are orthodox versions of this
which is that
there's a mystery in which there are
moments in your spiritual life where you
actually feel empty where you feel
disconnected from god where things
actually
break apart and that you don't
understand what's
going on
um and that you it really is kind of
this it's related to baptism symbolism
you could say it's related to the fact
that you have to kind of go down before
you go up
and you have to break down your
presuppositions and break down
your false understanding
in order to
not just intellectually but like even
physically and the way that we
what we trust and the things we we that
give us joy and the thing so it's a kind
almost like a kind of spiritual
depression you could call it and uh and
saint john lacrosse talked about this as
a necessary
part of the spiritual life where we go
down and then
then god brings us
back up
um
and you see that in in several of or
even recent orthodox saints who talk
about descending into hades and
let's say
staying in death staying in hades and
that just staying in hades is kind of a
breakdown of your pride and of your
of your of your presuppositions
um
so that god can pull you out let's say
at least that's my understanding
so our murray says you have some
favorite stories from irish or celtic
folklore could you briefly
share one of the main symbolic themes
that arise in the story i'd be honestly
i don't really know a lot of celtic and
irish type
so i don't really have an example which
comes to mind
yeah
so lynn holland is if the best parts of
christianity to put love at the top of
the hierarchy then would a society which
would sphere the topic would be
anti-christian
totally not talking about the western
reaction to a respiratory virus here
yes i agree i think that you know
there's a
recently my in my uh
recent video that i did on uh saint from
the syrian and uh
christ walking on water you really see
that relationship where christ goes down
to the disciples and he says
rejoice be not afraid for it is i
and i think that the relationship that
relationship you draw between fear and
joy or fear and love
is definitely the difference between a
kind of tyrannical system
and uh and a true
yeah true communion so
so leo says reggaeton is a dance beat
that appears to have spread around the
world faster than kogit
i don't i don't i don't know what that
is
unlike other musical styles it only has
it has only one specific rhythm
currently in spain for example it's
practically the only type of music in
here now is any context do you have any
thoughts on the phenomena of reggaeton
no i don't i don't have a comment on
reggaeton i don't know what that is but
if you want to understand it you can
understand it rather in terms of fashion
in terms of when you're not attached to
when you're not attached to a higher
principle where you're not attached to
something which is binding you together
and kind of bringing it all together
what happens is that you have
you have little tyrants of attention
that's what fashion is and so instead of
having something which kind of mediates
the extremes and binds us together what
you have is these little things that pop
up and become the attention
and then go away and then they pop up
they become the attention they go away
and that's distraction it's a kind of
distraction and so these fads that show
up you know whatever fidget spinners or
whatever stupid fad
appears and vanishes after six months is
really an image of
of the problem it's an image of this
breakdown in meaning that we're dealing
with you know the idea of going viral
like the idea of going viral on youtube
for some stupid stupid meaningless
nonsense has to do with this it's like
like you have all this bubbling chaos
and all of a sudden
something for reasons that are
completely almost arbitrary
just kind of pop up and and
and and get our attention for 15 minutes
and then they vanish and you never hear
about them again and this
yeah so
that's what i think about that
so john valenzuenza says jonathan your
answer to this question will resolve a
dispute between me and my wife now see
that's not good that's not that's not a
good thing i don't want to i don't want
to get involved in the dispute with your
wife
all right a friend of mine recommended
exercising along with the youtube
channel called yoga with cassandra as a
way to improve my flexibility i find the
stretch is very effective and they don't
take too much time
my wife says that yoga is a part of the
buddhist liturgy and that is bringing
paganism into our home so my question is
am i bringing paganism into my home
i have promised my wife i'll abide by
your judgment man what is this
i'm counting on you don't let me down
keep up the good work well i have said
that i would not do yoga myself
uh and the reason why i would not do
yoga is because i do think that yoga at
the outset
in in
india
is usually a kind of spiritual practice
it's embodied but it's a it's a movement
towards embodying certain spiritual
principles or transforming yourself in
the light of certain spiritual
principles and so i feel like
because of that a lot of the
pop yoga that we see is
it's like this liminal space that that
that that we were talking about before
it's like these haunted spaces where
you have these residue of this yoga that
people just don't understand and they
don't know what they're dealing with and
see it as just stretching and so they do
these stretches and the thing is that i
understand that probably they're good
stretches because
there's no contradiction between you
know a spiritual practice making you
healthier and
and then also being a kind of you know
vehicle for something else and so i
think that's a problem like i don't
think that if you
i don't think you're bringing paganism
into your
your house but i think it's it's kind of
like
it's kind of like this weird liminal
space that we talked about it's kind of
like you've got all this stuff that is
half meaningful and you don't it's not
connected to your culture and you don't
totally understand you don't know what
you're doing the person who's teaching
it on the youtube channel doesn't know
what they're doing and so they're
getting involved in all these weird
patterns that they don't understand and
that they don't master
uh and so i think that it i would say
that beyond the specifics of people you
know getting healthier doing yoga i
think in general this kind of weird yoga
uh
obsession is part of the it's part of
the
the breakdown like it's just it's
participates in the breakdown so
i don't have an answer for you like i
like i said i'm not
i'm not saying you shouldn't
just do stretching or whatever and some
of these stretches are good i'm just
saying
my general perception of what i think
yoga is doing to our world let's say
um
so patrick moore sends me a video a
youtube video sorry patrick i can't
watch it he says video of australian
orthodox priest
um
government mandated vaccinations are we
there i have to watch it later i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna do that now so sorry
about that
um
so marcus anderson so
question about the symbolism of finding
treasure at the margin if you use the
causing mountain as an image why would
treasure be found where lawlessness and
unmorality increases at the edge is this
something related to the position of
showbread north and the temple thanks
i don't know if it's related to that but
for sure what it's related to is that
the world is full of god's glory it it
it always is
and so the margin in the potential
is hiding
sparks it's hiding potentials that can
rise up and become
very important and so
the idea of finding a finding a treasure
on the edge has to do with that has to
do with
out there in the darkness there are
things which are valuable
but that you don't necessarily recognize
yet and so
you can have the surprise of discovering
discovering something valuable hiding
there that's the symbolism of the
fishermen that christ talks about and so
you can imagine
throwing your net out into the nations
and then surprisingly finding
these these sparks of god that are
hiding there in the in the darkness and
so
and so that's what it has to do but you
can understand it in terms of uh
in terms of of a practice let's say you
you
you know you have a certain way of doing
things and it kind of works you know and
then there are all these possible ways
of doing things which most of them would
just be a waste of your time right and
so you have all these possible ways of
doing things and
possible other
tools you could use or other
things you could use but there's so many
that it's like it's just it's it's you
could lose yourself in there but
sometimes you have an intuition and then
you find something in the darkness
something in potential that you haven't
tapped in yet which ends up being
a shining light like something which
will then be integrated and will
bring about certain solutions that you
had never thought about that you had
never that you never could have imagined
and so that is also part of that that
kind of symbolism
um
so
so keenan wang as you mentioned sloth
has to do with attention and that
business can actually be thoughtful yes
uh what's the symbol is symbolic nature
of lust is there a way that the concept
is broader than normally expected
um and so yeah for sure in the sense
that
lust or arrows you know if we if we kind
of broaden it the idea of erotic
desire is definitely something which is
more than just
negative like there are some fathers
that actually talk i'm reading uh
timothy petit's book right now the the
the ethics of beauty and he clearly
explains how eros or lust or desire is
actually
supposed to be the driving force or the
motor towards in by which we are
actually
seduced by god that we fall in love with
god and we fall in love with the things
of god and so
and so
and so lust or arrows is not something
which is bad in itself uh it's just that
you know if it's directed in the wrong
direction then it can become a kind of
tyranny
so arie fisher says hey maximos
as i understand it verveiki makes a
solid case that the best way to
understand the process of relevance
realization is not
deliberative and teleological but
something more like an evolutionary
process
therefore a phenomenological description
that says
that this points towards that good
because the good
has something akin to will or intellect
is less accurate because it implies
teleology then a non-theistic conception
of the
sacred how would you respond
sometimes that sense there is a real
ground for new naturalistic
evolutionistic religion in this world in
his work would that be the antichrist
his sister don't ask if john viveki is
the antichrist what kind of question is
that his sister reminds me of time while
yours is more space perhaps we should
have faith
then that one date will crown
christianity um
so
i think i i've explained it several
times before which is that this is a
process which happens both ways it is
bottom up and is top down and so for
example
things point towards the good
to the extent that
you are
a being that recognizes the good
and so
you can't find that pointing towards the
good
in the meshiness of the process
it's above the messiness of the process
and as conscious beings
we perceive the good
and we see that things are moving
towards the good
and that good
sometimes is after the fact
appears to us after the fact is revealed
to us after the fact
but it's nonetheless true it's nothing
that's real and that good
nonetheless preceded
the process
even if we don't
even if we can't see the the causality
so
a very simple example like in terms of
so and a kind of evolutionary biologist
would say that eyes are not foreseen
that that's a that's that's not right
they're not they're not for seeing eyes
are a messy
bottom-up process of selection
and and and mutation and reproduction
which brought about
the capacity
to perceive
images and to interpret them or whatever
but eyes are not foreseen
but that's just not true eyes are
foreseeing they just are we know they
are we look at eyes and we realize that
those eyes are foreseen
and they and and whatever process
brought them about they brought them
about in order for them to be able to
see
and pay attention to an evolutionary
type biologist for 10 minutes and you'll
see that although he will explicitly say
that eyes are not foreseen you will find
that same person slipping five minutes
later and speaking in teleological
language because we are teleological
beings because we perceive teleology and
to just say that that is not real that
that is an illusion that that is
whatever
is to deny your experience it's just to
deny the experience of being the
conscious being which is perceiving
these processes
which is capable of naming them which is
capable of mapping them out we are the
ones doing that and we
see
telos
in
all of these things
and that telos
is real
because without consciousness doing
participating or cullman the culmination
of relevance realization something like
consciousness
nothing nothing really exists so
so i hope that answers that
it'd be good for me to talk to john
about it more and maybe kind of try to
work out a better explanation for it but
that's at least how i see it
all right so norm gomden says the
mystery of christ pierced right side is
inexhaustible referencing not only the
baptism and the eucharist even the
church but also to show that jesus is
the new temple
that is equal in visions as the river
flows out of the right side to the east
of it also matthew writes that those on
jesus's right are the ones to be saved
in my church though in the crucifix
above the altar christ is pierced on his
left side wow interesting
hmm
interesting i guess i've never uh i've
never seen that but
it's one of those things that
you have to not get too caught up in
especially left and right symbolism so
we can recognize
right hand symbolism let's say even when
it's on the left
and i've tried i've explained this
several times one of the reasons why it
tends to flip back and forth is that
when we say left and right it depends
from what perspective we're talking
about
and so because of that
this symbolism can tend to flip from one
to the other but even if it flips
it doesn't it still
is manifesting similar things um
and also it also possible that your
crucifix is just a it's just an
idiosyncratic crucifix because
idiosyncrasies happen all the time
people get tradition wrong people make
things up people
modify tradition and then there's a
process by which those like your
idiosyncratic crucifix will probably be
the only one or there will be a few of
those
and and the one with christ
being pierced uh
on his right will
win right will will will end up
surviving and the other one will just
vanish
um
so kevin patterson says peterson talks
about knowing your your own capacity for
danger
or don't be harmless so that people will
respect you
what's the symbolic meaning of this
growing a spine while aiming to live
peacefully it feels like a descent into
division
um
um i mean i i don't think it's the it's
the only way there i think there are
other ways but i understand it i
understand because there's a there's a
difficulty
in that people can mistake uh
cowardness for humility
and uh that's definitely not what christ
is talking about
you know and so the idea of being meek
and of being you know
of being nice
can can be done not
through love or through a detachment
from your passions but can be done
through cowardice so i think that in
that case this type of discipline is
better for sure
uh
you know than just
thinking you're thinking you're virtuous
but actually just being a coward
so dorothea says is there a feminine
symbolism to archery i'm thinking here
of the goddess diana and the japanese
priestesses their sacred weapons was a
bow and an arrow
i didn't think about that
never thought about that at
all
um el dorado what is the symbolism of a
shooting star
hmm
that's why have i never thought about
that
huh
like what what does it mean when you
have these
these these
celestial things that kind of uh are
moving in the heavens
i wonder if that's also not part of the
symbolism of the fallen falling angels
if shooting stars didn't participate in
that type symbolism
and you guys are asking really tough
questions
hmm
it's also i'm running out of steam it's
what's going on all right amy hi
jonathan have you read
gravity and grace by simon wheel
it really impacted me especially
specifically our idea that we must
create a void within ourselves and in
that emptiness is where god can exist we
must lose ourself if the void is
unexpected hatred
arises and in that same void is hell
what's your take on this
that contradicting attributes arise from
each other so when one does good there's
also rises in evil which one must put
into themselves instead
of the world
i mean i never read this so i don't
really
totally understand i think the idea of
creating a void is definitely something
true like this that a kind of
self-emptying is the way in which god
fills you that's why ascetic practices
and
humility are part of the christian image
[Music]
and so but i'm not sure about the whole
unexpected hatred thing i'm not sure
because if it's unexpected hatred then
it's not a void is it or it's a fake
void or something so
that's why i'm not sure
all right chandler turner says recently
i've been more frequently encountering
this idea of anti-natalism which i
cannot wrap my mind around really last
week i went down the rabbit hole of
reading some of the stuff including a
particularly disturbing passage about
this supposedly feminist simone de
beauvoir and it seems as if these
individuals are uncomfortable with the
idea of having bodies or even existing
at all
is this simply nihilism taken to its
logical conclusion how does one argue
against such a perverse ideology
for sure that's what it is uh
and also
it's a misunderstanding of morality and
it's a misunderstanding of the purpose
of reality
it's a it's a misunderstanding of the
way in which suffering
can be transformed
rather than the idea that suffering
should be eliminated from the world so
antenatalists usually
usually
think that
suffering itself is
immoral and therefore we should
eliminate
hum eliminate life so that not eliminate
but at least don't not procreate
so that there's less suffering in the
world
and yeah i think it's a very very dark
and disturbing and um
wrong way of thinking because
at least it's not christian that's for
sure because christ shows us rather how
how
christ fills suffering with meaning you
know how christ transforms
death into glory
and that's the ultimate
that's the ultimate uh
solution to that
so
and people like simone de beauvoir and
you know they
let's just say their lives weren't great
and uh these anti-natalists
i imagine their life must be pretty gray
that's all i can say
so drew mcmahon says jonathan what are
your thoughts on cremation is okay for a
practicing christian
what is it symbolism thank you and the
answer is at least in orthodox circles
you're not supposed to
be cremated
uh you know that your body is supposed
to return to the earth
so no i don't think it's okay for
christians but it doesn't mean that if
you get cremated or go to hell or
something like that but i think that
it's a it's a perception about the body
and a way in which we treat the body of
the dead
and the way that we understand the body
is decomposing in the ground
i think is a very important part of the
story and the
the reality of decomposition
um
and let's say the story part of that
trumps i think the
cremation has a very practical way of
dying and uh in a cheap way to have a
funeral and a way in which you can take
up less space in which you're more
environmentally sound or whatever i
think these are all false reasons i
think these are all secondary reasons to
the vision
of from dust you came you know to dust
it will return the idea of of a
decomposition
and the surprise of resurrection so
yeah
so pogbama says what do you think of the
therapeutic use of hypnosis
it's being increasingly used to help
with weight loss addiction forbids etc
is it something christians should avoid
and i wouldn't get hypnotized that's
never happening
i would never give my will over to
someone else and so i'm not a big fan of
hypnotism sorry man i i don't know like
i don't i think one of the problems with
hypnotism is that i don't think people
even understand what it is and so
because they don't seem to even
understand what it is
yeah i think it's scary
and also i think i don't know it's just
something about it that's so unchristian
about putting yourself in a situation
where you are sit are you where you are
open to suggestions where you are
you know in a suggestible whatever
state of mind it doesn't sound right to
me
how jonathan how do we say dispassionate
in an extreme situation especially while
facing fear
i experience the abyss before describing
orthodoxy and the memory of that sensory
experience can cause me to feel like a
soldier trembling
in battle as same axis would describe it
any advice
thanks
i would say pray man i don't know
i don't know what else there is
to pray the jesus prayer
and uh
as the saints say you know
to um
hide yourself in christ right to to to
use christ as a cover
all right so conor mitchell as it is
quite clear that the pattern of coercion
surrounding the
shot is almost a perfect match with the
coercive message described in revelation
regards to the mark
however there is also a place for an
authority to withhold privileges and
direct behavior in adjust order as well
is there anything explicitly
demonic about the shot itself aside so
i'm not using the words because i don't
want to get banned aside from it
inappropriate place in the hierarchy
more important than attending church
desiring to determine what levels i
comply in a profession that i'm sworn to
follow orders um
yes
there is another aspect of it which is
disturbing which is obviously the
difficulty of
the difficulty of injecting a foreign
substance into your body now there's
nothing wrong with that in itself it can
be a garment of skin it can be a
a medicine
but the idea that you would inject a
foreign substance into your body
in order to be able to participate
in
society itself your own society your own
identity your own church your own
businesses you know not not the idea of
going to a foreign country it's already
very different right because a lot of
people are using that that excuse saying
they're already
vaccine passports right when i went to
africa i had to get vaccinated for the
yellow fever and for for all these
things but this is not the same this is
an interior identification which is
which is branded by
the receiving of a of a foreign
substance into you and so
i'm not saying i don't think it's
demonic
but i think that it is pointing in the
direction
which has to do with
the idea of the strange
as a marker
of identity and the idea of the strange
of
documenting the stranger using the
strange as a method of calculation to to
um
to account for everything as i've said
you know and so it's has strangely
something to do with the
the
explosion of gender identities right the
idea that that these strange markers
become
it's almost like a weird inversion it's
like something strange something foreign
is is that which shows that you belong
to the society and so it's like a weird
upside down thing um so anyways so more
coming in
in my video if i ever
have the
the wisdom to do it
so mido muhammad ali muhammad ali hi
jonathan what are your thoughts on
idealism basically argued that
consciousness is fundamental
and the nature of it is mental not your
mind alone or mind but mind at large
mercy and so
why is it that i don't like idealism or
why do i don't like the mind only
solution
and the reason why i don't like it is i
i dislike any theory that posits that a
major aspect of reality is an illusion
it just said no it annoys me from a
phenomenological point of view
it just annoys me and so we are the
minds
we we we we are the minds in which our
experience is happening
now
we can posit higher minds when
christians do
um
and we can posit the
the kind of existence this fractal
existence within these higher minds that
culminate into the one or into into god
or into
infinite mind let's say
but i think that
positing
the let's are negating the existence of
the of the lower beings
and negating the existence of body or
negating the existence of the material
world
and saying it's an illusion and saying
that your own experience that your own
experience of being a independent being
is an illusion all of that stuff just
it actually ends up just being
meaningless to me it just it it's real
to the extent that it's real it's real
to the extent that it has reality you
know and maybe it points to something
more maybe points to something higher
but it's but it's real so
i hope that makes sense when i explain
it that way i don't know how else to do
it
um
all right so romel says
there was another i i guess i had
forgotten this part here
uh could you please elaborate more in
the symbolism of dogs i've seen an old
lecture that you talked briefly about
dogs marking ends crypto
and cerberus and saw that kind of
applies also in the context of
xenocephaly and the canaanite woman yes
but i'm still struggling to understand
how all that is associated with dogs so
why is it dogs because dogs are
extensions of humans dogs are tamed
animals they are
animals that are the extension of the
will of humans that's why
but they're also an immediate danger
because of that because they're so close
to us there may be the animal that is
the closest to us in all of creation is
the dog
because it follows your orders you can
train it you know it has a
even can kind of be humanized in the way
in which you interact with your
dog um but because of that it also so it
marks the limit between humans and
animals because it's like
it's like the place where animals and
other animals
right so human dog and then other
animals and so that's why it also marks
the limit
but it's also dangerous because that
energy can turn against
other humans can turn against you all of
that can happen because they're so close
to you then they can maul you or they
can bite you where they can
yeah
so kelly madden asks in his book
matthieu says humanity's impetus in the
universe can adequately be summed up as
informing matter with meaning and
expressing meaning with matter page 50
is that how we should understand in part
the lord's foundational command fill the
earth and subdue it that's exactly how
you should understand that
it's exactly i should understand that
and so it's like imagine humans moving
out and filling up the earth and
therefore
giving meaning in name to all the
potentiality which is there and so
that's what the subduing is so you fill
and then you subdue in the sense that
you make it participate in meaning
um
so yes
so adam schillard hi jonathan my recent
seizures have had me thinking about the
symbolism of seizures my most recent one
came before the healing of the epileptic
sun i know symbolism isn't good or bad
so don't hold back thank you so
yeah i'm sorry i saw that adam that you
were that you were having seizures again
so i was i was uh i was quite sad to see
that but um
i mean seizures are
seizures are breakdown between heaven
and earth you know they're they're a
moment where
your body
uh
goes into frenetic
uh uncontrollable movements that you
don't control
um and so
so that's what seizures are they're
they're um they're a manifestation of
the of of a
break in communion between that which is
above and that which is below
yeah
so
that's what it is
all right guys it's 10 13.
um
and so let's see we've got
a lot of super chats
let's see let me just kind of move
slowly through these i feel i should be
super tired but i actually
have some energy i took a nap before the
the babylon v interview because
uh so anna chillard for five dollars
says uh last month's question did you
come through what is the symbolism of
seizures
uh is saint christopher a saint of
epileptics what that is what i've seen
online so there's adam again sorry adam
yeah just answer your question
i i haven't seen this idea that saint
christopher is the saint of
epileptics but i also haven't looked
into it it wouldn't so totally surprise
me because
because of what he represents in terms
of an excess of body you could say and
so you can understand you know the idea
of
a seizure as that the body taking over
let's say
so um so it's possible it would be
interesting if that were the case
i still have that little icon of saying
christopher adam carved this little icon
of saint christopher out of soap one
time a long time ago in one of my
classes and i still have it
so further wrote what's your diet like
during quarantine jonathan for five
dollars usd and so i couldn't taste
anything so i didn't really care i
wasn't really hungry too because
it's just weird when you don't taste
anything uh and so i just ate two meals
a day and they were very simple you know
mostly protein and uh
and vegetables
so it was just boring i don't remember
really what i was eating because
i didn't really care it was just all
cardboard to me
so saint george for ten dollars he said
did you see the kanye events in the
final when he sets himself on fire as a
baptism symbol and ends
with a wedding
i didn't watch the events
because i don't have apple music but i
i did see some highlights of it and uh i
don't know man
you know connie is 50 50. you know
kanye's 50 50.
so
so i don't know you know i can
understand the setting on fire
and i did see those images of the
wedding which was odd because it's with
his divorced wife which is just kind of
weird
uh
you know maybe he still loves her or
whatever i don't know i don't know so i
i to be honest i didn't think much of a
lot of these these events
um
yeah i don't totally get what's going on
with him right now i don't it's like i'm
watching him i'm not sure
what's happening um
and it has to do with the the feeling
that i that his album is a little uneven
and i don't know exactly what's what's
happening
um
so parker for 499 usd hi jonathan what
is the symbolism of forging weapon like
a sword out of a meteorite seems to be
common in fantasy stories thanks
i mean
it's a heavenly sword you know it's a
sword that comes from heaven it's not
it's not that complicated it's like a
sword is already
a kind of image of
of light or
of this thing that comes down you know
this
judging you know all of that and so the
idea of making a sword out of a a
heavenly stone
um
it's not so strange you know
um so lion says
may i have your top three books that
bring you the fondest memories not
including the bible please i'm a
bibliophile and love to collect
um
i would say
like if it's if we're talking about like
adult adult life
uh some of them
some of the stories were like the novels
that it really kind of stayed with me
um
i would say of course uh
the brothers crimes of by dostoyevsky
um
also the glass bead game uh by hermann
hesse j i know that story just really
stayed with me just this
this kind of image of a this beautiful
game um
um
and then in terms of
uh
another book which really uh
stays with me quite a bit just because
of what it is that i ended up being
involved with is a book that i just
bought back because i lost it in the
flood i have it right here
it's called that it's called the myth of
the dog man
uh by david gordon white and reading
this book is the first place in which i
encountered the legend of saint
christopher
um and uh
he's a really fascinating guy because he
really has an intuition about symbolism
and he gets some of it wrong because
because he he's also has a kind of
desired virtue signal and tends to see
symbolism of dog-headed men and of
monsters only in the negative
light that is it's only an image of
marginalization of
of dehumanizing the foreigner all of
that which is true that's part of the
symbolism but even though he says that
he still ends up pointing
despite himself or through that he ends
up pointing to
the
traditions that say for example that the
dog had in men were gardens were
guardians of eden or that
you know that there is this positive um
this positive aspect to uh
to the dog-headed man symbolism and so
he kind of ends up pointing to it i was
actually thinking of inviting him on the
podcast
uh but so we'll see maybe i'll do that
but he's he's kind of like
you know he's he's this guy he's like a
yo he's like a yoga tantra guy you know
he's all into that kind of stuff so so
i'm a little i'm a little hesitant to
invite him but it could be an
interesting conversation
uh so maybe those three books are some
of the books that that uh have kind of
stayed with me quite a bit and obviously
the crisis of the modern world by
reneging was a huge had a huge huge
impact on me because it it really marked
a transition uh
you know for my life life of moses
obviously these are books you already
know about so i tried to find something
else that you didn't know about
um
so ray fleming for uh five uh british
pounds i noticed that hair has a double
symbolism of being dead material on the
one hand but also symbolize glory
does this apply
to all marginalia i mean not necessarily
to all marginality but it applies to
marginalia which is that for example in
marginalia let's say in a in a
manuscript you find both ornament and
monsters and ornament is is a form of
glory right uh and so you're right and
so this is this is the thing that i'm
telling you guys about about the
connection between death and glory and
how one can become the other and that
that seems to account for a lot of
the symbolism from genesis to christ is
how death and glory seems to be
something like the same thing but
one
you know a different a different
different direction let's say
so louis duran says why was the idol
made after the flight of egypt the
golden calf well because it animals are
at the bottom of the mountain right it
has to do with the garments of skin um
and and also
the bull or the the calf as this support
you know like this kind of lower part of
reality so i think that's what it has to
do with in terms of symbolism it has to
do with this idea of animality at the
bottom of the mountain
so v2 zui says how do we know where is
the true church among all the options is
an educated guess the best thing we can
do
or is there a symbolic way to find it um
and so i mean i did i i did my own like
i i went on my own path and i and i
think
that i i do believe that the orthodox
tradition
because it has preserved the most
mystical vision of christianity because
it has preserved uh
the image of theosis and the image of
you know the stage of christ as feeling
of the world all of these things which
are a little bit there in other other
denomination you could say but for sure
i've been preserved more fully in the
orthodox church and so
i can only say it from my experience
so purple dinosaur five dollars would
you make of near-death experience
phenomena
hearing various accounts has helped me
shake me out of materials mindset
i was inculcated with i mean i know a
lot of people that say that for some
reason i'm suspicious of them uh
i'm suspicious of them because i think
some people are lying
uh i think some people are not telling
the truth uh
i think some are you know the some basic
things that people seem to experience
um seem seem interesting you know like i
said the light at the end of the tunnel
like that's obviously a very simple but
very powerful image of
of of a of a transition right between
two worlds uh and so there are different
things like that but but some people
they go really far in their descriptions
and some of those descriptions are shady
in my opinion so i'm a little suspicious
of them
but i'm happy if that doesn't help you
let's help you to kind of
break your materials mindset so carlos
vargas 499 usd says
hey jonathan my question is will the
church have a specific role to play in
terms of evangelization and the revival
after the death of christianity
um and so i think it's important to say
like i i kind of say christianity is
dying christianity is going to die but i
think it's really important to say that
at least at least
christ says that the church will not
completely die
you know
because he says you know the doors of
hades will not prevail
upon
upon the church
so i think that
we have to see it as this kind of
descent
but not a complete disappearance and not
a complete death and so
i do believe that the church will play a
role in reseeding the world you could
say
i don't know how i don't know exactly
what that means but for sure the body of
christ will participate in that
um so the new guy for 49 do angels of
humanity are they capable of love are
they simple simply obeying the
commandments of god without emotion
um
yeah that's tough those are tough to
answer
i think it's
um
i think i think angel's uh care can care
for humanity
i don't know about love
i think we're i mean we're definitely
called to be united in love with all the
angels and so maybe
uh it's just hard because the angels are
just not the same kind of beings we are
and so
they're they're kind of intelligences
and so it's hard to really
it's hard to square some of
trying to imagine what it's like to be
uh to be just an intelligence uh yeah
uh
so the new guy says
uh for 999 it was the other examples of
god being amused by something or
displaying a sense of humor
and where are the boundaries of humor
crassus vulgarity and such nor macdonald
funny but wrong or mcdonald's
uh
there are examples of god uh
being amused by something or displaying
a sense of humor
um
the the of course the the image of the
the the idol which is brought into next
to the uh
the ark of the covenant is brought next
to one idol i forget it's an idol of
hoove ball i think and then in the
morning
the statue ball is kind of falling down
on his face and is broken you know and
you have this image of god basically
uh
act you know foiling uh foiling these uh
these false gods and so those are like
moments of
humor
um and so uh so yeah so that's a that's
an example
i think they're probably
other examples but i just can't
necessarily think of them right now
so samuel ramilera from 5brl says
goodnight jonathan can you please
elaborate more on the symbolism of dogs
but i think i did didn't i didn't i just
do that i think i did that
i don't think you could do it again so
if you're expecting more a samuel sorry
uh so red redmond for 99 euros
uh hi jonathan are you familiar with
that sorry the philosophy of bronze age
pervert
no i don't know who that is
if you think it is compatible with
christianity he's a pagan he's quite
popular among young christian men online
so no i don't know who the bronze age
pervert is and he has a very strange
name so he doesn't necessarily uh
he doesn't necessarily inspire
confidence with the name like that at
least not for me
um so the new guy 999 usd says can
fallen angels be redeemed does the bible
ever indicate that angels think feel or
behave in ways like we do consequently
being able to fall and possibly desiring
redemption impossible
uh and so
first i would say the official line is
that no is that angels uh cannot be
redeemed because they
they don't
die they don't change and so that's the
official position
um
but it's difficult it's such a difficult
it's such a difficult
discussion because
say it this way like there is a manner
in which
the angels exist
in the mind of god as in their
eternal
so i don't totally see how all this
jives together but let's say the
official the official stance is is just
that no so yeah so nathal condon uh five
dollars no question thanks ted n for 10
usd can you speak a bit about how the
bible orthodoxy
et cetera is not about morality i grew
up in more convert-type communities in
the states and found a lot
of moralism bled into church at times
and so
um i mean it's about morality downstream
but it's not firstly about morality it's
really about
it's about worship and it's about
liturgy and it's about transformation of
the person into the image of god into
god himself you could say that's what
it's about it's a morality or practices
or spiritual disciplines end up being
about
healing and not so much about just doing
what's right or wrong you know there are
reasons why certain things are
considered wrong is because they make
you a slave to sin make you a slave to
passions make you a slave
uh
you know to these these fragmentary
desires
um and and we have to be able to break
free from those by
developing true spiritual practices by
reattaching ourselves to higher
principles ultimately you know
finding examples in the saints and and
attaching ourselves ultimately to christ
himself
and so so that's what i mean when it's
not about morality it's not about you
know
if you do this or you don't do this god
is happy with you or god is mad with you
because it goes against the moral order
it's like yeah
i mean you can express it that way to a
certain extent it's not completely
legitimate but it's it's lacking let's
say it's lacking in
the in the image of
the reason why god created the world in
the first place which is
to be united to his creature and to
to kind of this overflow of love
into creation is called back into god to
participate in his life
and that has little to do with morality
the way we understand it um
so jack of all trades comics uh for five
dollars usd what are the limits icon
carving what should and shouldn't be
carved
i mean the limits of icon carving are
the tradition of the church we we we
basically follow the tradition that the
church has given us you know unless it's
an image that has never been carved then
we then we
tend to be a little more we have some
flexibility
um
and so that's what kind of that's what
kind of uh designated it's not a set
process people talk about iconographic
canons as if they're written down
they're not written down they are just
basically the received tradition of the
church and so there's obviously some
discussion there's some disagreements
it's not a completely clean process but
uh it nonetheless is something which
works itself out
um all right so the new guy again wow
for 19.99 usd you've done a video on
batman why not on his primary
inspiration the shadow i think you'd
find the character fascinating he's
better than batman best source
online is the shadowcast on youtube just
a thought i mean yeah i don't really
know the story of the shadow very well i
know about him but i i don't know
um
i know that i know that uh they made a
horrible movie i didn't even watch it it
was it's like this horrible
movie that looked like a sin city or
something that they did wasn't it
yeah
uh so daniel lopez for 35 gtq i don't
know what that is uh
is it wrong to attend the catholic and
evangelical church at the same time
there's no orthodox church where i live
is it wrong i mean
it can be confusing it can be confusing
to kind of just go to different
churches especially if you're doing it
regularly
um
so so i would say yes for sure you
definitely wouldn't want to take
communion in both places
and i don't think if your priest if the
catholic priest knew
he definitely wouldn't wouldn't agree
shouldn't agree that you can
take communion in both places um and so
i would tend to
i would definitely tend to kind of
to choose also just not to be kind of
ripped apart um
and so you know it's like i
this is not ideal but you know i because
my you know
my my family is protestant and so i
i have been called
several times to go to
protestant churches you know for
different reasons for different events
or whatever and so it's like i'll go
um
obviously it happens rarely and and i'll
go and i'll just i'll just be polite and
i'll be there and i'll and i'll you know
i'll
smile and be nice to people
um
you know but i would never take
communion there that's for sure so i
would say be cautious not that not to be
kind of ripped into pieces so
so anderson smith 499
no questions thanks man
um so i think i think we're done with uh
with with pretty much
everything and so is it is it me or did
we basically spend
like the entire
the entire uh q a without
without uh moderators who's the
moderator who's there in this chat i
didn't even see
you guys
anyways
so um
so yeah so uh
so thanks for everybody thanks for
thanks for your time uh you know thanks
for your attention thanks for everything
sorry that the month of august has been
a little weird less videos than
i guess i usually i usually put up but
um
but hopefully i'll be able to catch up
this month and in the next few months
and so stay tuned for the things that i
talked about my discussion with jordan
peters and john vicki my discussion with
jay
dyer uh babylon b all that stuff
and uh and so yeah and so i'll be
posting on social media for people who
want to participate in that event in
month the
society of jung event if you want to
participate in that i'm going to make
that discussion a little more technical
maybe than i usually do or maybe i'll be
willing to push it a little more in
terms of uh
you know in terms of of um
talking more about structure and stuff
so yeah so we'll do it all right guys
so um so it's good to talk to everybody
and oh frank growly's there so keeping
an eye on yeah so we did have a
moderator there it's good to see you
frank
uh and then someone says uh
we must be so well behaved this time i
actually feel like that it's true i
didn't see because often i kind of see
scrolling of a sudden i see like all
these messages being like you know
removed or being blocked or whatever
because of these spam bots and all these
this stuff so uh
yeah who knows so um so thanks everybody
and uh yeah stay tuned i will see you
next month thanks again for everybody
who's supporting me i really appreciate
it and um and talk to you very soon
bye-bye